everybody's watching this video i'm
about to make you a ton of money in a
few minutes i'm gonna walk down exactly
how you can price stuff to get more
people to buy really expensive things
that you sell and if you don't sell
something really expensive you're gonna
want to by the end of this video right
now if you can write down on a piece of
paper what the average price of the
thing that you sell is let's say it's a
hundred bucks what i want you to do is i
want you to put 10x i want you to put
50x i would put 100x next to it now once
you write the price of what that would
be if your main thing's 100 bucks 10x is
a thousand 50x is 5 000. 100x is 10 000.
it doesn't matter what business you have
if you want to make lots of money
sell more expensive stuff there's no
strategic benefit to being the second
cheapest person in the marketplace but
there is for being the most expensive
there's only one strategic benefit to
being the lowest cost person in the
marketplace which means that you went in
with that strategy and you built an
entire business around operational
efficiency automation and you built the
whole strategy of the business on being
able to provide the same thing for less
if you did not do that and are simply
trying to do the same business as other
people and compete on price you will
lose you will have no profit left over
and you will get price to the point of
breakeven and you will just run a
non-profit thank you that's probably not
why you got into business no matter what
you sell you should have something
that's 10 50 100 times more expensive
than thing you're currently selling when
i bought my first nice suit for myself a
friend of mine was like fashionable and
he like took me to the store or whatever
i put a suit on i remember checking the
price tag and it was thirteen thousand
dollars homie didn't have thirteen
thousand dollars and i was like [ __ ] and
then what they did is after i took that
off they put me in a suit that was like
twenty nine hundred bucks or twenty 2
500 and i was like okay i can get with
this right i didn't realize it then but
they had completely price anchored me
and that was 100 the strategy was get
put you in the most expensive suit and
then you're like geez but the thing is
is that some guys will look at that and
the right guy will be like done i'm in
price anchors have two benefits and this
isn't the only point of the video this
is the first point for everybody who
isn't going to buy the really expensive
10x 50x 100x thing you anchor the rest
of your pricing against that first price
so you're showing them this thing kind
of like ripping off the band-aids like
stretching the length through which they
see your pricing if i say a thousand
dollars first and then i say a hundred
thousand dollars it's like [ __ ] that's
huge but if i say a thousand dollars
first and then i say
a hundred dollars or ten dollars that
sounds like less if you have a pricing
menu for a membership for example of any
kind you want to have the most expensive
one first not the least expensive one
and then everything else will look
cheaper by comparison if you do it with
wine you can do with software you can do
with memberships it works in every
situation because it works on psychology
now let's talk about the other side of
the equation all right so we've got the
anchor and then we've got other options
of pricing so how do we organize the
other two options good question i like
to use the small medium large example to
kind of like break this down so you can
use this as small medium large popcorn
small medium large cokes whatever but
let's say you've got 10 bucks five bucks
and you've got this middle price where
you put this middle price will indicate
which product gets sold the most of a
certain percentage people always buy the
cheapest thing because that's who they
are and that's fine the next people are
influenced by the pricing in general so
if i have a five dollar thing and a ten
dollar thing i can make this medium six
bucks so i make my medium a dollar more
than my small and it seems like a great
price but the thing is to ever forget is
that we make up all the prices all of
these are made up so we got 510 and we
got six or 650 or 6.99 and we're gonna
get a lot of people are gonna buy this
one now
if i bump this to here nine dollars and
i make this 10
what are people going to do a lot of
people are gonna buy this one because by
comparison it's like wait just for a
dollar more i get twice of the small
well that sounds like a great deal and
so fundamentally people want to buy
great deals they don't want to buy cheap
stuff think about the difference there
price is what you pay value is what you
get the deal is the discrepancy between
the two for example and this is a big
one this is a i want to break this
belief for you if right now you sell
expensive stuff five thousand dollar
things or ten thousand dollar things if
i were giving you a ferrari
brand new and i said it's ten grand and
i'm walking up to people on the street
and they believe that i was actually
going to give them the ferrari
how hard do you think it would be for
them to come up with 10 grand
what would they do
they would call their friends they'd
call their family they would take out of
their credit cards they'd take a loan
why because they know it's worth more
than 10 grand whenever you are selling
something expensive the reason someone
is not buying it is simply because they
do not understand the value because if
they understand the value and they
believe that you're giving them a
ferrari they will find a way to get the
money i want to banish this whole
concept of like they can't afford it
everyone can afford it if they believe
the value is there and so the idea is
not that we're giving cheap stuff away
we want the value relative to the price
to be a huge bargain when you're coming
up with the stuff that you're going to
sell the first thing that i want
everybody to do 10x 50x100x pick one and
then figure out what you would have to
fulfill to make it worth that they are
getting a ferrari for 10 grand and
that's how you get people to say yes
over and over again and the other thing
is is that it'll start to teach you that
people are willing to spend more when
they see the value the other benefit of
having this huge price anchor is that
whales will buy it so a certain
percentage of population just like i
said certain percentage population
always buys the cheap thing because
that's who they are there's another
percentage of the population that always
buys the most expensive thing because
that's who they are it doesn't hurt you
at all to have something that's super
expensive on your menu put it there with
the expectation that you're never gonna
sell
and be surprised when you do if you
didn't get a gasp from the price you
didn't go high enough you want that gas
because that gap shows that you've
broken the rubber band of pricing that
they associated with what they expected
your product or service to be priced at
and so if you're like oh it's 100 grand
they're like whoa i was not expecting
that you're like oh no worries and then
you can explain why it's worth it but
then it's like you know what i think we
can do 80 of that for 10 because that's
our our silver that make more sense for
you yeah that would make a ton of sense
for me now if silver's 10 bronze is 8
and gold is 100 you need to sell a lot
of 10ks because now it seems like
nothing it depends on the customer or
segmentation but one of the big mistakes
i see people do is that they'll have
like 100 a month 110 a month and 120 a
month you want to meet buying personas
so you might have a hundred dollar a
month you might have a 200 a month you
might have a thousand dollar a month
because the people and the needs between
those customers are different so you
want to price based on the value
delivered to a specific avatar like if
i'm selling something to coca-cola it's
going to be more valuable to coca-cola
than it is to a local brewery so you can
price it accordingly if you are a cro
expert conversion rate optimization and
you can help an e-commerce store buy 10
if the store is making a million bucks a
year 10 is 100 grand if the store is
doing 100 million dollars a year 10 is
10 million you literally can provide
more value to them because of who they
are not because of who you are so 10x
50x100x think about what you provided
for each of those levels put that at the
top of your menu be the first thing that
you explain to people expect 1 out of 20
to say yes to it and for everybody else
to feel much more comfortable taking the
other options bye